[MUSIC PLAYING]
MARK: OK.
So it's been an amazing
week, and hopefully
you still have energy
for some more cool stuff,
because we have one more
cool announcement for you.
And we have some Google
magic in the demos.
In Google, we put
customers front and center.
We care deeply for the
experience we provide.
And we've been on a journey
for the last 15 years
building planet-scale services.
By doing that, we
learned a few things.
We learned that
experience is driven
by providing performance,
reliability, availability.
And in order to
provide those things
we developed a culture, which
we call site reliability
engineering.
And site reliability
engineering is a combination
of people, which is all
of you and many of us,
practices, which we'll
talk a little bit about,
and products that we are
making available to you
as part of Google Cloud.
So we have cool demos.
We even have very interesting
giveaways at the end,
so I recommend staying.
And to move to the
exciting stuff,
there's nobody
better to tell you
more about that than the person
that's branded and created
site reliability engineering.
The person that his
LinkedIn profile simply
says, if Google stops working,
it's probably my fault.
Ladies and gentlemen,
please join me
in welcoming the VP of
Google 24 by 7, Ben Treynor.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
BEN TRAYNOR: Thank you, Mark.
So thank you all
for joining today.
I want to talk a bit about
a new product announcement
that we've got, which is the
launch of the Transparent Cloud
API.
And to do that
announcement instead
of talking at you myself
about how cool it is
and all of the things
we expose, I actually
want to introduce someone
more qualified than myself
to talk about how
useful this is.
Lingyun from Snapchat,
please join me.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
And have the [INAUDIBLE].
[APPLAUSE]
So, Lingyun, we all
know that Snapchat
was an incredibly
popular application
during the FIFO World Cup 2018.
Things were happening fast.
People were sending Snaps using
their cool Snapchat goggles--
spectacles, excuse me.
And we also know that the
load was incredibly high.
It was one of the most
popular events ever.
How did Snapchat keep
everything so snappy?
During the event, how
did you guys end up
stealing the show like that?
Please, speak into the
spectacles and tell me.
All right.
[LAUGHING]
LINGYUN RUAN: Thanks, Ben.
Hi, everyone.
I'm Lingyun, and Snap engineer.
So Snapchat is a best camera to
share the moment with friends.
During the World Cup,
there were traffic spikes,
or backend, after
each important goal,
which means users were
sharing their excitement
at this exact moment by sending
Snaps or posting stories
with our top class lenses.
Publishers also created a lot
of World Cup-related stories
for our user.
We really want our users
to have the best product
experience on Snapchat.
That's why we need
a strong server
infrastructure that assures high
availability and low latency.
So to optimize the service for
different types of stories,
we have this
complicated backend,
which consists of a great
number of components.
Each component can depend on
multiple account services.
To run a complicated
system like this well,
we need a good monitoring to
understand its performance.
We also want to discover and
the root cause issues fast.
But this is
especially challenging
if it will run your
service on the Cloud.
Because often, you rely
on this Cloud products,
which are usually black
boxes in modern-term world.
Let's simplify the problem.
So if we take away all the
implementation details,
we'll see some simple
diagram like this.
There are three
parts in the system--
client, our services,
and the Cloud products.
Just like what people usually
do in the cloud world,
our services rely on
these Cloud products
to serve a request from client.
And then we try to make the
best use of this Cloud product
so we can focus on
the implementation
of our own business logic.
We wouldn't spend effort
re-inventing the wheels
as long as this Cloud product
can meet our service quality
requirement and are
also cost-efficient.
To tell whether the whole
system is running well,
we would add monitoring
in different places.
So first, we need to understand
that the overall healthiness
of this system.
So we usually add
serving metrics
including traffic, errors,
and latency to our service.
This metrics at direct service
level indicators that tell us
how well the system is running.
And then we also set up
alerts on these metrics
so we can get a
notification when
the serving quality degrades.
During a outage, we want to
know which part of the system
is broken.
And a service can have
multiple internal components.
It can also depend
on other services.
For these internal
components, we
can add custom metrics to
measure their performance
directly and tell
which path goes wrong.
What about these
outgoing dependencies?
So people usually
add constant metrics
to measure the errors and
latency for the request that
to go to our dependent service.
These constant
metrics are helpful.
They are [INAUDIBLE] to indicate
whether we are having issue
calling our dependent server.
But the problem is they don't
tell us where the issue lies.
The issue can locate
either under caller side,
or the dependent server
side, or it can be
an actual issue in the middle.
Thus, people usually wanted
to check their serving metrics
of this dependent service.
So it can compare them
with the [INAUDIBLE] ones.
And only through this
kind of comparison,
we can get a better picture
of what is going on.
If we're on the
dependent service,
we can get into
some metrics easily,
by either adding
instrumentation, or just
issuing a monitoring agent
to correct these metrics
if they're already available.
But what if the dependent
service is a Cloud product?
In the traditional
cloud world, we
can't get a survey
metrics of these products.
But now, Google is offering
visibility to its customers
under this transparent
SLI effort.
So let's walk through
a for-real use case
to see how this transparent
SLI images are helping us
with production debugging.
So let me use this simple
service as an example.
So this is one of
the subcomponent
of the complicated story
service backend, which
is shown in previous slide.
And this service is one
our story services that
serves stories metadata
in search result.
So when you type something
in the search bar,
to reduce a
[? search ?] one size,
we don't include the full
metadata of these stories
immediately.
The client will
only send a request
to fetch the full
metadata of that story.
Only when user clicks on story.
And we store these stories
full metadata in Cloud Spanner.
And we built this simple serving
layer and deployed on GKE.
So this service just translated
request from client side
into Spanner
queries, and execute
to the queries on Spanner, and
then returns the result back
to the client.
Very straightforward, right?
Then let's discuss
how we are going
to build a dashboard to monitor
this simple serving stack.
So the most important question
we want to answer in this case
is, is this story
service performing well?
Thus, we added our serving
metrics in our first row.
From left to right, this
charts our request and errors,
error ratio, average latency,
and a 99% [INAUDIBLE] latency.
These are all well known
as our [INAUDIBLE] signals.
We can get a good sense
of the service level
with a just [INAUDIBLE]
single glance at this row.
And this service just a
single [INAUDIBLE] of Spanner.
So when there is a
production issue,
the first thing we want to
check is whether these Spanner
requests are doing OK.
So heuristically, we added
this Spanner constant metrics
into the second row.
In the past, if we didn't see
something from these two rows,
we would start to guess.
Maybe Spanner is having issue.
But we could not be
100% sure about it.
Because this constant metrics
don't tell us the full picture.
And in an outage our
users are impacted,
and we really want to
mitigate the problem
as soon as possible.
And then we wish
we can see directly
behind the curtain
and to shorten
this procedure of verifying
different hypotheses.
Luckily--
[ALARM BELL]
Sorry.
Luckily, Google--
BEN TREYNOR: We don't
want to hear that.
LINGYUN RUAN: Yeah, I don't
want to hear it right now.
BEN TREYNOR: I don't think
we have to hear that yet.
Let's keep looking at this
issue on the dashboard
that you've got.
LINGYUN RUAN: OK.
So luckily, Google now is
offering us this visibility.
So we can put this Spanner
transparent SLI metrics
on the third row.
This metrics directs Google-side
performance indicators
of how well Spanner
is handling requests
from this particular
Snap service.
We will see [INAUDIBLE]
how this metrics can
help us locate issue fast.
The rest rows are
resource metrics.
We always want to
make sure resources
are provisioned properly.
In the first row,
we have the charts
which show Spanner resource
metrics, including,
per table Spanner
instance securitization
and per table operation rate
and errors In the last row,
we have the charts monitor
our services resource.
And from left to
right these charts
are-- per instance
CPU [INAUDIBLE],,
memory [INAUDIBLE],,
and network traffic.
So in all, having a dashboard
with these five rows
we can answer the
question, is it
a Snap issue or a Google issue,
faster during our incident.
Just the [? sign ?] over here,
Google exposes dashboard API,
so we can configure our
dashboard like this using code
and keep track of all the
changes in our code base.
This feature is currently
under a earliest access program
and we really enjoy it.
[ALARM BELL]
BEN TREYNOR: Uh-oh.
Lingyun, there's
that sound again.
I think something might
actually be wrong.
What are you going
to do about it?
LINGYUN RUAN: Let
me check the page.
Don't panic.
Let's check the page.
Oh, OK.
This says our server ratio
has jumped significantly
for this story service.
Don't panic.
Let's open the dashboard
and take a look.
So now we are looking
at the dashboard
we just built together, right?
So remember in the old
days, we would have started
from these first set of rows.
And let's see.
In the first row,
are our story matrix.
We can see that our
ratio has jumped
with latency, which is a
common scenario in a production
outage.
And it's usually the case,
that either the processing
on the server side is slow
or there's slow backends.
And number of errors
that is climb as we
request [INAUDIBLE] a timeout.
And then let's look at the
second row, or our Spanner
client metrics.
And we can see, this
chart align real well
with this in the first row.
Since Spanner requests are
taking longer to return,
is it a Google issue?
Usually, at this stage we
will file a support ticket
to check with the
support engineers.
But now we don't have to.
Now we can look directly at
the third row, this Spanner
transparent SI metrics.
And let's see.
This says, no errors.
And we can also see
some latency increase.
But if we take a closer
look and compare the numbers
with the numbers
in the first rows,
we can find something
interesting.
Client latency
increased 10 times more
than what the
service side shows.
So it implies maybe it's not
our issue on Spanner side.
And the Spanner side
latency increase
can be a result of a
slow client [INAUDIBLE]..
So at this stage, let's continue
investigating on the Snap side
instead of filing a ticket.
So let's look further
down in the dashboard.
From this Spanner
resource metrics,
we can see our Spanner
instance actually
are running with
reasonable CPU [INAUDIBLE],,
which is another signal
that it doesn't support
it's a Spanner-side issue.
And then we move
on to this resource
metrics of our service.
Here we go.
We found that when the incident
took place, the CPU [INAUDIBLE]
of one of the server instance
jumped to something crazy,
like 100% utilized,
while the CPU [INAUDIBLE]
for other instances dropped.
It usually indicates the
traffic is not balanced,
and the one single instance
is serving almost all
of the traffic,
which is pretty bad.
And we checked around
and found someone just
wrote the balance configuration
change, so let's just
fix it with a revert.
So we've just gone
through an example
of how we're using
different metrics to root
cause our products and issue.
This can be just
one possible version
of the story in which
this transparent SI
metrics helps us conclude
it's a Snap-side issue.
And we save a lot of time by not
creating a false alarm ticket
to Google.
As you may know, communicating
over the support ticket
is very time-consuming, even
if the support engineers
are responsive.
This is because
support engineers
need to understand your
service, your environment,
and the real issue before
they can start investigation
on their side.
And it takes a lot of back
and forth communication
for this code [INAUDIBLE].
The whole story can
be a different one
if when we look at the
Spanner SI metrics and found
it's a Google-side issue.
In that case, we can
just create a ticket
and point the support
engineers to the exact metrics
we looked at, which also makes
the communication faster.
So as a summary, we really like
this transparent SI metrics,
as they give us
additional usability
and also help us save time
in production debugging,
no matter if it is a
Google issue or not.
All right.
Thanks for listening
to our story.
Let me hand it over back to Ben.
[APPLAUSE]
BEN TREYNOR: Thank you, Lingyun.
So yes, as Lingyun
has just illustrated,
this sort of scenario
actually happens
every day in production, right?
Things work differently.
You have variations.
And one of your first
jobs, especially
if you have that klaxon
going off in the background,
is to figure out what
has occurred, right?
Something has changed, but
was it a user behavior?
Was it a push that you made?
Is something going
on in the platform?
Historically, the way
that this would get done
is you would look
at your application
and then file a ticket,
and 20 minutes later
somebody from support
would get back to you
and you'd joint debug, and
all this time, time is passing
and your users
are being damaged.
And if you can make
those intervals shorter,
if you can make the period
between when the klaxon goes
off and when your service is
working normal again, much,
much shorter, all of
your users are happier.
And your engineers
are more quickly
able to solve the problems
that they are introducing,
either intentionally
or otherwise,
with the changes
that they're making.
And so this introduction
of the Transparent SLI
and the Transparent API for
all of Google's services
is a huge step in
that direction.
It lets engineers at
companies like Snapchat
spend more of their time
developing and rolling
out cool apps and less
time debugging problems.
So I'm happy to announce today
that the Transparent SLIs are
available for all
Google services,
and they give you the same
key signals that we actually
have learned to use
internally at Google
in the site-reliability
team to manage all
of Google's infrastructures.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you.
You know, this both,
from my perspective,
helps everyone develop and keep
running their favorite services
on Google, and it helps us
apply a little bit of what we've
learned over the last 15
years of running Google's
internal cloud, and make
it easy for all of you
to develop your applications.
And it helps you minimize
the time between when
something unexpected occurs,
and when you've accurately
done a differential diagnosis
and have either said,
this is something that
we can change on our own,
or we need to contact Google.
And if you do
contact Google, you
can send the screenshot that
your application monitoring has
sped up, and we won't
spend any time trying
to figure out what's going on.
We can dive right to
the heart of the issue.
Finally, even in
developing applications
when nothing is
going wrong, it's
very useful to be able
to see details of what
the backend services are doing.
Not just the median
latency or the error rate,
but actually the
latency distribution,
and what happens over the
course of the last week.
And this lets you build
applications that are better
suited to the performance
characteristics
of the infrastructure
that you're running on.
If you would like to
learn more about this
and other cool production
development practices,
we have access today
in Stackdriver.
We also have access today
through our partner Datadog,
who takes a lot of
this to the next level
and gives you
integrated dashboards
and value-added services.
And we have The
5th Nine, which is
the Site Reliability
and Customer Reliability
Engineering.
Lounge is open today
until mid-afternoon.
And if you come by and
visit, not only will you
be able to talk to
SRE's and CRE's,
but we have free copies
of our launch edition
of the second volume
of the SRE book,
which I highly recommend
with no bias at all.
And you'll be able
to talk to people
and maybe even get
your book signed.
So Lingyun, thank
you for showing us
how you will use this service.
Thank you all for attending
the launch of this
and I want to now
introduce Morgan, who has
another announcement for you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
MORGAN MCLEAN: Hello, everybody.
Thank you for coming.
I'm going to do a demonstration
today of our Stackdriver APM
tools.
So for those of you
who happened to watch
the keynote this morning, or a
part of the keynote on Tuesday,
we made reference to these.
In fact, this morning
we did a live demo.
And so our APM suite is aimed at
developers, first and foremost.
So this RPM suite includes
Stackdriver Trace,
which allows you to view
how requests propagate
through your application.
Stackdriver Debugger,
which allows
you to do safe breakpoint
style debugging,
safely in production.
And Stackdriver Profiler,
which is our newest addition.
It's a continuous
production profiler
that allows you to see
how your code actually
executes while it's running.
So rather than do a
presentation or a deck,
I'm just going to
do a live demo.
Part of this was captured
in this morning's keynote,
but part of it also--
the debugger part--
is new.
And so I'm really excited
to show it to you.
So if we could switch
the screen to my laptop.
Perfect.
So this is Hipster Shop.
If you've gone to
any of the keynotes,
you're probably already
familiar with it.
It's a demo application
that's composed of, I think,
seven or eight services, some
of which are written in Go,
some of which are written in
Python, Node.jp, and finally,
.NET Core.
We've gone and
instrumented it so that it
works with Stackdriver, and it's
running on Google Kubernetes
engine.
This version is not using SDL
like the version of the Tuesday
demo, not that that
really makes a difference.
Also unlike the
version on Tuesday,
this version is incredibly slow.
We're very happy it wasn't
like this during the Tuesday
presentation, but we've
gone and slowed it down
so we can find out why.
And so I clicked on
vintage typewriter,
it takes a while to come
up, I click on add to cart.
A lot of these interactions
exhibit very, very poor
performance.
And because it
appears to be just
all these general
interactions are slow,
things like application
level metrics,
like latency metrics for
a particular service,
aren't going to be
especially useful.
Because with our strongly
interconnected web services,
a slowdown in one is going to
cause slowdowns in all of them.
What we can use, though,
is distributed tracing.
And distributed
tracing allows you
to track how a
request propagates
between different parts
of your application
as they actually happen.
So this scatterplot here
on the vertical axis
shows the latency of
captured requests.
On the horizontal
axis, we have the time
in which they were captured.
And you can click between them
to view the different traces.
And when you click
on one, you see what
we call the waterfall graph.
This waterfall graph shows
the different components
of a request.
So in this case, it's
the different services
that are hopped between
as the trace was captured.
And so from here,
we can see that this
was a call made to
the cart endpoint
of the front-end
service, and then
it went to the currency
service, and recommendations,
and finally it started going
to product catalog service.
Now we see two things
are a problem here,
and we went over this in
this morning's keynote.
The first is that we're making
a ton of separate requests
to product catalog service.
This just seems like
bad design, right like?
Like if we're viewing a set of
data for a particular product
or looking at
something for the cart,
we should probably be
calling the catalog
a single batch request if
there's multiple products.
And if there's only one
product, we should really only
be calling it once.
That's going to
take a while to fix.
Like, there's some real
re-engineering there,
and I'm not going to bore
you to tears in the demo
while I rewrite the application.
But the other thing
that we can investigate
is why these individual
requests are slow.
So even if we batched
these up, this
would take still far too long.
Our trace that had--
what's that, 10
seconds of latency--
would still have well over one
second if we batch together
these product catalog requests.
You can see this individual
component is already
1 and 1/2 seconds long.
And so the trace doesn't help
us go any deeper than that.
You can add custom components
to the trace using our APIs,
but still, generally
you won't understand how
the code is actually running.
And so to do that, we can
jump to Stackdriver Profiler.
Stackdriver Profiler is a
continuous production profiler.
It's the newest component
of our APM suite.
To you, as a developer,
you basically
turn it on your application
and forget about it.
And it continually
captures information
about how your code actually
executes in production.
The nice thing about
Stackdriver Profiler
is that compared to similar
entries in the market,
it has effectively no
performance impact,
so you could just leave it
running in the background,
which it will sample itself.
It'll turn on and off
and various services
at different times.
And to you as a
developer, there's
basically no performance cost,
which is why it's really nice.
And you don't have
to worry about it.
You don't have to turn it on.
You don't have to start
profiling sessions at random.
It supports Heap, thread
profiling, and CPU profiling,
depending on the
language that you're on.
It will also do
wall time profiling.
We're going to jump
into CPU profiling.
And we can see
something right away.
The Get Product endpoint of this
service, the gRPC method for it
is really, really slow.
It's consuming 92%
of our system's CPU.
If we run a language that
allowed all-time profiling,
we'd also see that.
And we can see that effectively,
all the time for it is taken up
by this parse catalog method.
And so what we can do
now is dive into the code
and see what's actually
happening there.
So this is the parse
catalog code here.
This is inside our
product catalog service.
It's written in Go.
And we can see here when it's
called it basically just does
some JSON de-serialization.
And so from going from
trace, we understood
which service was calling a
slowdown for our application.
Without distributed
tracing that would
have been incredibly difficult.
And now with Profiler, we found
the actual function in our code
that's slowing everything down.
So in just a few minutes,
or a few seconds depending
on how quickly you
went through this,
we can find out exactly
where our slowdown is caused.
And this might seem like a
bit of a contrived example.
Like, in fact, if you
looked at the code,
you'd see that I made this
use JSON serialization
to slow it down for a demo.
But for when we talk
to our customers,
this isn't so outlandish.
We've talked to many customers
where their services are
slow because
they're just burning
CPU time on serialization,
de-serialization,
or where they have things like
regular expressions, or just
functions that, you
know, you wouldn't even
expect to show up as
a blip on a CPU chart
or really a list of things
that are slowing things down.
And it's consuming 10%, 20%,
30% of their system's CPU.
And so this is
actually an example
that's really, really
appropriate for things
that our customers
have run into.
And so in the demo this morning
that I did at the keynote,
we then redeployed the
service and fix the issue.
So I'm not going to do that
here and repeat everything.
What I will show you is that
between the different versions
of this code, we can
compare the performance
with the new Stackdriver
Profiler comparison feature.
And Stackdriver
Profiler comparisons
allows you to compare
profiles from your services
either across versions, or
across different time periods,
or across different regions.
And from this, we can
see that the slow code
here, particularly
our parse catalog,
has gone to,
effectively, 0% CPU.
And even the get product
endpoint, which of course is
still there in the new version,
is now down to effectively 0%
CPU.
And we can use this to verify
that our code changes had
the impact that we expected.
Obviously, if you were
doing this in real life,
you'd want to start by doing the
metrics comparison of latency
just to verify that your
changes have worked.
But with this, we know that
the changes inside the code
have actually had the
effect that we wanted.
For Stackdriver Trace, we
also have a similar feature
where you can compare
latency across time,
or across versions, or
across different areas.
So I mentioned that
Stackdriver APM
is composed of three products.
So I mentioned
Stackdriver Trace,
I walked you through
Stackdriver Profiler.
Finally, we have
Stackdriver Debugger.
Stackdriver Debugger,
just like the other tools,
you can run safely and
continuously in production.
It is very sort of
magical in a sense.
It lets you set breakpoints
in your production environment
safely.
We call these snapshots.
And so the best way
to show this is just
to give a demonstration.
So the code I'm looking at here
is for the currency conversion
service.
This is a service where
you can call in, give it
a value in US
dollars and tell it
I want to know what
this is worth in euros.
The Hipster Shop store
lets you change currencies.
The currency service
is what performs this.
So one of the challenges that
you might have with a currency
conversion service is that it
might be converting currencies
in a different manner
than you expect, or it
might be converting them
with the wrong values.
So the way the service works
is every hour or so it goes
to a web service, I think hosted
by the European Central Bank
or something like that, that
lists their up-to-o-date
currency conversion rates.
So let's imagine that
you looked at those rates
and you looked at the values of
the currency conversion service
was outputting and
they didn't match.
Today, to debug
this, you'd probably
add a bunch of log
statements to the service
to print out what it thought
the current currency conversion
values were.
You'd go and redeploy
the app, which
might take a while, depending
on your environment,
and then you'd see the
output of those logs.
With Stackdriver Debugger,
we can short-circuit that.
All I have to do is click here
on line 123 in the interface.
We've already
captured a snapshot.
There's a load test
running against this.
And from here, we can look
at the local variables,
like this data objects,
and see the actual values
that the service thinks, in
memory, that it should be
converting these currencies at.
So right away you can debug
it and verify your hypothesis
that the currency conversion
values were wrong.
You can verify if
that was correct.
We also, just like a
traditional debugger,
support full
conditions so you can
tell it to only set a snapshot
if certain variables are
set to certain values.
And you can use expressions
to inspect the output.
Finally, you can navigate
through the different frames
in the call stack.
I admit that this is
probably not the greatest
example because this node
function calls itself a lot,
but you can also
view the variables
within those different frames.
So it gives you
the power that you
expect of a regular debugger
without halting execution,
without interrupting your
customer's workflow, which
is really, really,
really excellent.
We use technologies like this,
Profiler And trace every day
at Google, and we're really
excited to show these
to our customers.
So we should talk about
two things with these.
The first question
that always comes up
is, how easy is this to set up?
I can tell you from experience,
from working on this demo app,
as well as just,
of course, working
on these products a lot, it's
very, very straightforward.
So we do in-process
instrumentation, simply
libraries that you link to your
application and redeploy it.
All of our instrumentation
is open source
and Apache licensed on
GitHub across all languages.
For Trace and for Debugger,
we support Java, Go, Node.js,
.NET, Ruby, Python, and PHP.
So we have a set
of seven languages.
For Trace, we
additionally support C++.
For Profiler, it's
relatively new.
So we're still building
out the language support.
So we support
Java, Go, and Node,
and we're developing support
for Python right now,
and then we'll continue
looking at the others.
For Stackdriver Trace,
our instrumentation
is through a project
that we started at Google
and we still run
called OpenCensus.
OpenCensus is a set of
language-specific libraries
that will automatically
capture traces
and application-level
metrics from applications.
So for example, in
this application
here, by adding
OpenCensus to one
of the Go parts of the
application of these lines
of code here, we
automatically captured
traces, propagated contexts,
embedded annotations
and attributes and those
traces, and we automatically
captured
application-level metrics.
So it's really easy
to get started with.
We have integrations across
all these languages for things
like GRPC, various HTTP
clients, SQL clients,
other storage clients,
client libraries for Google,
and so on.
And we try to make it as
automatic as possible.
OpenCensus is also
great because we
have this concept of exporters.
And this is the
reason OpenCensus
is a community project rather
than just a Google project.
So when you set
up OpenCensus, we
told it to export
to Stackdriver,
but if you were using
other APM solutions--
we mentioned Datadog earlier.
You can export to
Datadog by OpenCensus.
Or Prometheus, or Zipkin,
or Solarwinds, or others.
You can export your data
to your backend of choice.
And with OpenCensus, you
can export your data even
to multiple backends at the same
time, which is really powerful.
So we've made this really
easy to get started with.
You simply link a few
libraries, including
OpenCensus to your application.
They'll automatically capture
the right telemetry, redeploy
your app.
You can get started
with Stackdriver APM.
The pricing on Stackdriver
APM is extremely competitive.
Debugger and Profiler
are currently free.
Trace has a pretty
generous free tier,
and then there's a paid
tier after that that
goes into effect in September.
Compared to competing
solutions, it's
like a tiny minuscule
fraction of their cost.
So with that, I'm done the demo.
And we'll move on
to the next speaker.
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]